for someone who's never heard of the
hero's journey how would you explain it
to them and maybe you can use some film
references yeah
absolutely the hero's journey is an
approach to storytelling that initially
was
observed in stories that had been told
in the past the hero's journey in many
ways initially was meant to be
descriptive of stories that had existed
is opposed to
prescriptive for how to tell a story now
since Joseph Campbell identified the
hero's journey or what he referred to is
as the monom myth a term he borrowed
from James Joyce the monomyth is meant
to describe this
process that Campbell broke up in 1949
in the hero with Thousand Faces into
three different
sections there's what he called the
separation or the departure stage and in
this stage a hero departs and leaves
that which they've known before so many
times this happens as a result of a
character that loses everything or life
at home becomes
unsustainable in Star Wars Luke
Skywalker comes back home to find his
aunt and uncle have been killed and the
morning
farm that he lived on has been burned
there's nothing there for him anymore in
Mobi dick however ishmail tells us that
he wanders around the docks and that
there was just nothing of interest for
him there anymore and he decides to go
out on the Open Sea so it can be that a
character is pushed out and separated
from their normal world or it could be
that that character
chooses to go out on their own adventure
because life has either become boring or
there's just nothing for them there
anymore the second phase of the hero's
journey is called the initiation phase
and it's in this phase after the
character has been separated from their
Norm normal world that they go through
all sorts of challenges the initiation
phase is what builds character within
that protagonist they go through all
sorts of troubles trials tribulations
that end up creating something within
them that did not exist
before in that initial separation
phase the protagonist is usually in
desperate need of therapy of some
sort and it is through that initiation
phase that they're going to get what
they need therapeutically that will
allow them in the Final Phase of the
journey which is called the
return to do what they need to do what
people often get really wrong about the
hero's journey in these three phases is
that that Final Phase is about taking
whatever you discovered whatever you
found the treasure that come to life for
you and bringing it back to the
community that you initially
Departed the hero's journey is not about
an individual ego going and becoming a
more enlightened or greater version than
themselves the hero's journey is about
bringing
back the wisdom the treasure what Joseph
kampbell called The
Boon back to the land the people the
community that need it the most this is
why it's heroic is we bring back what we
found and we share it with
others why do you say that the
protagonist must feel dissatisfied in
order to embark on their Journey a
character needs a certain sense of
dissatisfaction to be able to embark on
their Journey because otherwise they
would never leave home there's no reason
to go on a journey if everything is
great where you begin
with in the story of Moana we see a
character who in the very beginning is
having a great
life but there's still something that
causes her to feel like she's not com
connected to the community that she
lives in she's feeling like there's
still something
missing and she sing a beautiful song
about what that missing piece may be but
she knows whatever it is she's looking
for lies Beyond this Village that she
lives in it becomes very important for
her character to leave that which they
know one of the reasons why this is in
every great story about a heroic journey
is it mirrors the human psychological
process that we embody as we get older
and grow up if there were no reason to
ever uh uh leave our parents home and go
and get a job and and Embark out on life
ourself well then many people would and
many people do to be quite honest stay
and live at home and it causes this
psychological condition called AR rested
development it causes people from
becoming who they are supposed to be in
the world this is why it has become an
archetypal Motif that as people get
older and reach their late teen years
there often starts to be great conflict
between themselves and their parents
it's a natural process that causes them
to have a great desire to leave their
normal world that which they've known
and go out on the journey in order
to have the struggles and and find the
treasure that they need and then bring
it back to start their own
family they'll have kids that have that
exact same reaction to them and the
process is very mythological as it
continues over and over again how does
the hero's journey mirror the way we as
humans solve problems the essence of the
hero's journey is really a formul ation
a metaphor of sorts for how human beings
solve
problems the same process that we go
through in solving a problem we find it
in these great heroic
stories what initially happens is the
awareness that there is a problem is
what starts this this journey in in
taking place so we have to recognize
that why
something's
wrong this is why the essence of all
story is conflict because without
conflict we just have scenarios we just
have situations but once we have
conflict we have a story I like the way
that Blake Snider used to put it in his
book save the cat he talked about a cat
sitting on a blanket is just a scenario
it's just a
situation but a cat sitting on a dog's
blanket now we have a story we've got
conflict we've got characters so once
that conflict is
established then we can begin to look
for
Solutions and it's very core
storytelling is about setups and payoffs
and that
setup really is identifying the problem
being able to
articulate what the conflict looks like
the payoff is how we solve the
problem an artist use just a bit of
poetic license to do that in a way that
the audience might not fully
expect this is why the hero's journey is
a story that keeps being told over and
over and over again because we never
Tire of seeing the multitude of ways
that people solve problems
there's something
reassuring about seeing that where I see
a character solve a problem on screen
and I say ah maybe there's Hope For Me
Maybe if that character can solve their
problem maybe this issue that I'm facing
can be overcome as well does the hero's
journey always have to be in
order
yeah the hero's journey often does not
appear in the same order that Joseph
Campbell laid out in his book The Hero
with a thousand faces many times all the
stages and steps of the hero's journey
don't appear in a story as well here's
the way that I like to explain the
hero's journey and even storytelling at
large I think works the same way imagine
for one second that I brought a large
glass vase and inside that glass vase we
poured every every element of
Storytelling everything there was to
know about characters and and worlds and
uh plot and everything you could ever
imagine about story every stage of the
hero's journey every Nuance to every
stage of the hero's journey and we put
it all inside this glass face and we
dropped it on the ground and it
shattered into a million
pieces every artist and storyteller
it becomes their responsibility to pick
up those shards and create their own
Mosaic on the wall from those shards it
doesn't necessarily mean that we're
going to put this Shard before this
Shard it doesn't necessarily mean that
we're going to use all the shards that
are there but this is where the artistic
nature of Storytelling becomes so
beautiful in that you are going to to
pick up shards that I might not pick up
you're going to arrange those shards in
a completely different order than I do
this is why that the hero's journey is
such powerful tool because it can be
broken into a million pieces and yet put
up into a new creation in a way that
feels fresh to us every single
time storytelling as well as the hero's
journey is not about formula it's about
form here's how we know the difference a
while back some friends of mine were um
they were giving Tango lessons and so I
went and took Tango lessons with my
friends and my friends showed me the
formula for Tango they showed me you
move this foot here and then this foot
here and this foot here and this foot
here and let me tell you I did not learn
how to dance tango at all by learning
the formula but one night they took me
to a manga late at night and I sat in
that manga and I watch people begin to
move with the music and move inside the
music and I saw the living form of Tango
come to
life they were using those steps but not
in the way I was trying to use those
steps the hero's journey storytelling
it's a form it's a form form it's not a
formula we can learn the steps we can
learn the stages but really seeing it
come to life and be powerful it's about
when that form begins to take over every
writer knows that form when suddenly the
words just start start coming out and
we're not even consciously aware of
what's Happening we're in the zone we're
flowing and we're moving within that
form of Storytelling